ellen said and i'm quoting i don't know
rosie we're not friends
rosie o'donnell going into detail about
her rift with ellen degeneres
it hurt my feelings like a baby and i
never really got over it on watch what
happens live a fan asked why rosie never
appeared as a guest on the ellen
degeneres show during its 20-year run
because ellen appeared on her talker at
the rosie o'donnell show in 1996.
i was just playing around she could find
sit down noah on the go
the subways divine at a quota tonight
it's the rosie oh donald shell there you
go thanks for flying in for this hey
you're busy well and i love being with
you so whatever and that's when ellen
jokingly came out as lebanese ahead of
coming out as a lesbian on her
self-titled sitcom
i don't know how this leaked out either
because we were really trying to build
this up slowly and reveal it uh
in a way that would be you know
just
change people's opinions basically
we do find out that the character is
lebanese and uh
yeah yeah
just out of the blue she just no it's
there have been clues i mean she's
you've seen her eating baba ganoush if
you've watched the show at all
which leads us back to this question
were you really never never
did they not ask no
really no like we had a little bit of a
weird thing and after my show went off
the air and hers was coming on the air
um larry king was on with with ellen and
he said whatever happened to rosie
o'donnell her show went down the tubes
she came out as a lesbian and
disappeared and ellen said and i'm
quoting i don't know rosie we're not
friends
yeah and that moment stung rosie a bit i
was in bed with kelly and i went did i
just hear that or was that like a
hallucination auditory voice in my no
and that's what happened and it hurt my
feelings like a baby and i never really
got over it however rosie did reveal the
show invited her to be a guest they
asked me once at the end towards the end
uh i i was going to go on for smelth but
i wanted to bring someone with me
because i thought it might be a little
less awkward right and they didn't want
to do that but at the end of the day
rosie holds nothing against ellen i wish
you were all good things in her life and
that she should be well so they said
there you go but i never did it
[Music]
you